previously on Gamespot news if you want
to play The Legend of Zelda tears of the
Kingdom you're going to need to Fork
over some money and now it might be more
than you were prepared to spend
yesterday evening the Nintendo switch
eShop showed a 70 price for the highly
anticipated sequel this might be
confirmed to be true by the time the
direct drops later today or it might be
debunked let me know in the comments
which it was
[Music]
well everyone it's been confirmed tears
of the Kingdom's standard edition will
indeed be 70 and Nintendo has commented
on the price point when reached out to
by Game Informer regarding the 10
increase from the usual 60 Nintendo has
been charging for their switch titles a
PR rep for the company stated that
future increases would be chosen on a
case-by-case basis insinuating that that
has always been the case despite 60
being consistent for the console's
entire life cycle Nintendo clearly has
an understanding of how big tiers of the
kingdom is going to be as it's keeping
the 60 price point for its other first
party title Pikmin 4 a game that won't
sell even remotely close to what Zelda
will breath of the wild sold nearly 30
million copies almost 20 million more
than the previous best-selling Zelda
game Twilight Princess when the switch
launch title went on sale it was
initially outpacing sales of the console
itself
Nintendo is probably looking at the new
standard set by both PlayStation and
Xbox and despite not releasing more
powerful Hardware figures it can get
away with matching that standard If
Tears of the Kingdom sells 30 million
units that's 300 million extra dollars
the company can add to the pile and
considering the switch is now the third
best-selling console of all time 30
million seems like a conservative
estimate time will tell if the price
increase has any effect on sales a game
Nintendo was putting out that is
actually a decrease from the 60 price
point is the long rumored Metroid Prime
remastered which is out now via the
eShop and will be available physically
on February 22nd retailing for forty
dollars this pricing is initially also
bizarre as typical Nintendo remasters
and remakes get the 60 treatment like
2021's Brilliance diamond and a shining
Pearl but again when you look at the
value of the franchise the best selling
Metroid game hasn't cracked 3 million
copies whereas Pokemon sales are always
in the tens of millions you're getting a
lot of bang for your buck with that
forty dollars as Metroid Prime
remastered boasts redone visuals updated
controls and bonus content this seems to
clearly be the best way to experience
one of the best games ever made Metroid
Prime remastered was one of a few
highlights from yesterday's Nintendo
Direct some of the others were another
look at tears of the Kingdom Game Boy
Game Boy Color and Game Boy Advance
games coming to switch online the former
2 coming to the basic tier and the
latter coming to the expansion pack
option and a look at Pikmin 4 gameplay
as previously mentioned Pikmin 4 will be
the standard 60 but if you were looking
to buy both it and tears of the kingdom
and are a switch online member you can
pick up both for only 100 a 30 discount
this is via game vouchers which are
available on the eShop to switch online
members where you can buy one 100
voucher and use it to pick up both games
if Pikmin 4 isn't your bag other titles
such as the year-long delayed Advanced
Wars OnePlus 2 reboot Camp which is now
releasing on April 21st or the upcoming
Bayonetta origins game are also
redeemable via game voucher head to
gamespot.com for the full list of titles
that can be Redeemed by game voucher how
do you feel about tiers of the Kingdom's
price increase are you having fun with
Metroid Prime remastered let me know in
the comments and we'll see you here for
more in Gamespot news
oh